Speaker 1: We got a call from a viewer last
week who brought up China and a discussion
of the portrayal of China in American media.
And during that conversation, during that
phone call, we talked about xenophobia towards
Asian-Americans over COVID.
We talked about intellectual property theft
and a few other topics.
And I got a very good email from Thomas over
the weekend, and Thomas said to me, You know,
David, there is a China story to talk about,
but it's not really what the caller brought
up.
Intellectual property theft.
It's an issue.
It's not the major geopolitical issue with
China.
There's no real evidence that China intentionally
released COVID is bioweapon, so that's not
really like the big story with China.
Yes, xenophobia against Asian-Americans for
real or perceived misdeeds by China is something
we should be against.
We're not going to be xenophobic against Asian-Americans
because of something the Chinese government
did that that's happening, and that's bad.
But Thomas wrote, there are real issues with
the Chinese Communist Party.
Now that's another issue to clarify.
The CCP and China, as in Chinese people, are
two different things.
We're really talking about the Chinese government,
the Chinese Communist Party.
And as Thomas wrote to me, there's a ton of
negativity towards China in general.
That's very surface level.
Some of it is based in plain old bigotry.
Some of it is peddled by U.S. media.
But there are many real reasons to be at odds
with the actions of the Chinese Communist
Party.
So let's look at the real concerns with the
Chinese government, the CCP.
And these are not reasons to go to war with
China.
Caveat.
I'm not suggesting war.
I know that there's people possibly on the
revolutionary left who will see this segment
and say, I'm calling for another American
military intervention.
No, the I'm not even saying these are reasons
to no longer trade with China.
If we stop trading with China would be disastrous
for the American economy, as it's currently
set up.
We're just going to talk about issues with
the Chinese government first.
The ongoing Wiegert Genocide Wiggers are a
Muslim ethnic minority in China.
China has been credibly accused of committing
crimes against humanity, possibly genocide
against the weaker population and other mostly
Muslim ethnic groups in the northwest region
of Xinjiang.
Leading human rights groups, including Amnesty
and Human Rights Watch, have put out reports
accusing China of crimes against humanity
for their actions.
There are reeducation camps.
There are horrifying things and much has been
written about it.
That's a real substantive issue with the Chinese
government.
Second, organ harvesting.
This is all that.
If you put a positive spin on it, this is
oh, we get organ donations from prisoners
who have died of natural causes.
That's the story that China would tell.
But a tribunal ruled in 2020 that China is
forcibly harvesting organs from prisoners,
prisoners who certainly didn't volunteer to
donate organs.
But it goes even further, possibly even prisoners
who are killed for organs not who have died
naturally.
The number of transplant centers in China
has gone up over 300 percent.
Wait times for organs have come down dramatically.
It's not clear why China doesn't have much
in terms of an organized organ donation program.
How is it happens?
How does it happen?
It seems this is a likely explanation, and
it is absolutely horrifying.
Note that back in 2012, a top Chinese official
said.
China is going to phase out the practice of
taking organs from prisoners who have been
executed as of 2020, we believe that that's
still going on even if it's not a side from
executed.
There's a lot of other ways that you can accelerate
the process of obtaining organs from prisoners.
It seems that that's being done.
Absolutely horrifying.
Number three, China so poorly mismanaged its
own infrastructure that it likely has led
to hundreds or more Chinese people.
It's hard to get real numbers from the CCP
to die due to flooding.
And the idea here is that yes, there have
been heavy rainstorms that are not manmade,
right?
Humans didn't make the rainstorms, but there
are serious allegations that the deaths are
a result of this infrastructure madness craze
in China, where money is poured into projects
that look good sometimes generate returns
for people.
But meanwhile, simple infrastructure that
could be improved to prevent senseless death
from heavy rains and people drowning are ignored.
OK, complete mismanagement.
That's a real criticism of what's being done
and then such corruption from the CCP that
causes all sorts of problems massive fraud,
embezzlement around these half finished villages
where people make a ton of money, the projects
are abandoned after the contracts in the cash
are handed out, as well as reconstruction
projects that never really happen, although
many people get rich from them.
And then lastly, and this is a really big
deal of China's continued aggressive posturing
towards India, Taiwan and the South and East
China Seas more generally, each of which we've
talked about a little bit in the past.
So on India, there have been somewhere between
four and 10 skirmishes of note between India
and China over the border, various face offs.
We've talked about it a little bit on the
bonus show before the situation in the South
China Sea involving China, the Philippines
and Vietnam, where you see military activity
by China, naval maneuvers, other aggression
outposts being built concerning and then also
conflicts with Japan in the East China Sea.
Other part of the sea it include it includes
Japan having scrambled jets in the past and
other escalation.
So to be clear again, I want to be really
careful.
I don't want war with China.
I'm not saying invade China.
I'm not saying the U.S. doesn't also do bad
things.
Lots of countries exhibit this type of aggression.
The difference is number one, a lot of the
criticisms of China in the U.S. media and
from, you know, people like Trump have been
very surface level and lead to xenophobia
against Asian Americans, which has no place
whatsoever.
There are actual horrible things being done
by the Chinese government.
Many countries that also want to do horrible
things don't have both the aggression and
the means to carry it out.
The financial resources at their disposal,
the massive population that China has bigotry
against Asian-Americans because of this are
Chinese people.
Anywhere is wrong and we're against it.
I'm also not saying cut off China.
From an economic standpoint, our economy is
now too inter intertwined with China.
It would take a really long time to be able
to untangle that relationship without destroying
the American economy.
So I'm not calling for that.
But there are real geopolitical issues here
and humanitarian issues about which we should
be concerned.
It's not bigotry to talk about that, and the
American media rarely touches these actual
issues.
Let me know what you think.
We'll have more on this story on the David
Pakman show Instagram, which you can find
at David Pakman show on Instagram.